A newborn killing nurse, a marble eating
mother, and a pop star whose fame is
thanks to a school shooting. You'll never
think of "disturbing" movies the same way.
The 2012 remake of Maniac had some mighty big
shoes to fill. The 1980 original is one of the
most renowned and reviled slashers of all
time. It's an appallingly intimate portrait
of a serial killer who stalks the streets of
New York City in search of vulnerable women to
work his mommy issues out on. Cut to 2012, when
the remake dared to ask: what if this already
skin-crawling story was shot almost entirely from
the first-person point of view of the killer?
Working against type, Elijah Wood plays
Frank, a deeply disturbed "nice guy" who
can't be reminded of his lack of a girlfriend
without killing every woman in the vicinity.
While Frank makes an admirable attempt
to date normally, he still has a bad
habit of draping women's scalps over vintage
mannequins. The result is a film that succeeds
in making Frank pathetic without also making
him worthy of our pity. And in the real world,
with the threat of violence perpetuated
by the rise of incels, the horrifying
plausibility of Maniac has only become more
and more disturbing all these years later.
2012's Excision follows a troubled young teen and
aspiring surgeon named Pauline. As her hormones
rage, her corporeal interest proves far more
carnal than clinical. Obsessed and outcast,
Pauline sinks deeper and deeper into her
blood-soaked fantasy life, where she dons
scrubs and bathes in the blood of patients
who are as much her victims as her lovers.
Wearing its depravity on its sleeve,
Excision dives deep into unapologetic
teenage boundary-pushing with a pitch
black wit and a scalpel in hand.
The film has no shortage of gore, but its
true disturbing power lies in its portrait
of a neglected, ostracized teen. Pauline's steady
slip into destruction has a clear and preventable
trajectory, so it's agonizing to watch the world
fail her at every turn. A coming-of-age horror
that fully embraces all the bloody realities of
morbid teenage angst, Excision is a fiendishly
offensive horror comedy about wanting to be
loved and accepted for the little freak you are.
"Can you contract an STD from
having sex with a dead person?"
On the grounds of a vague religious disagreement,
Thomasin and her family are banished
from society. They build their cabin on
the fringes of colonial New England, right
at the edge of a dark, forbidding forest.
One afternoon, Thomasin's baby brother vanishes
without a trace. Suspicious of Thomasin,
the family reasons that the infant
was spirited away by a witch with
dark intentions. As the days tick
by and the child remains missing,
a devious combination of isolation and
paranoia turn Thomasin's family against
her. As they descend into madness, it becomes
increasingly difficult to parse cabin fever from
the rumblings of an ever-encroaching force
that seems to be seeping out of the woods.
One of the key factors in the dread-soaked
atmosphere of The Witch is its adherence to
historical accuracy, making the
whole experience that much more
immersive. So when the supernatural begins
its infiltration in the family's homestead,
their struggle with unseen forces begins to feel
very real and threatening. Furthermore, the film
also invites you to see things from Thomasin's
perspective. She stands accused of unthinkable
acts. And the self-fulfilling prophecy of the
accusation is truly the stuff of nightmares.
"Baa, baa, baa, baa."
Run, don't walk, as far away as you can from We
Are the Flesh! Or if you insist on toughing it
out, don't say we didn't warn you. Released in
2016, We Are the Flesh follows brother-sister
duo Lucio and Fauna, who are doing their best to
survive in a post-apocalyptic hellscape. They're
then shocked when they enter a decrepit building
on the edge of town and find a man named Mariano.
Ignoring the fire in his eyes, the siblings
listen attentively to Mariano's devil's deal:
food and shelter in exchange for their help
in transforming a building into a cavernous,
womb-like temple to depravity itself. With Lucio
and Fauna firmly under his thumb, Mariano forces
the siblings to participate in unthinkable
acts of violence and fleshy transgression.
The end result is a combination of sexual abandon
and hallucinatory terror. We Are the Flesh is an
intense, explicit, and boundary-defying descent
into madness. Is it daring, or is it disgusting?
"Why not both?", seems to be
the answer of everyone involved.
It's relatively bloodless compared to the gorier
entries on this list, but The Killing of a Sacred
Deer is nevertheless a deeply unsettling viewing
experience. The film is a loose adaptation of one
of the most harrowing chapters in Ancient Greek
fiction, Iphigenia at Aulis, which tells of King
Agamemnon's ritual sacrifice of his own daughter
in exchange for favorable winds to sail to Troy.
Directed by Greek filmmaker Yorgos Lanthimos,
the film follows Dr. Steven Murphy, a successful
heart surgeon who appears to have it all. Then
one day, he meets a young man named Martin,
and the two form a special bond. It's only after
Martin inserts himself into the surgeon's family
life that he reveals his true intentions:
he wants justice. Martin's father died on
the operating table because Dr. Murphy
was under the influence. By supernatural
means that are never clearly explained
and are all the more disturbing for it,
the surgeon's two children fall ill. Dr.
Murphy is faced with an impossible decision:
he must kill one of his kids or
his wife, or they will all perish.
"It's the only thing I can think
of that's close to justice."
Much of
the uncomfortable atmosphere of The Killing of a
Sacred Deer comes from Lanthimos' intentionally
stilted direction. This endows everything
from the production design to the visceral
moments of violence with an unnaturally
clinical distance. And the creep factor
of Barry Keoghan's performance as Martin cannot
be overstated. From his candor to his voracious
appetite for spaghetti, everything he does
feels slimy and calculated. The thought of
innocent lives being caught in the teeth of
life's meat grinder is inherently upsetting,
and The Killing of a Sacred Deer
makes an absolute meal out of it.
The death of children is a running theme
on this list, and understandably so,
which is why we've got this film about a Satanic
cult hellbent on snuffing out as many innocent
lives as possible. 2017's Belzebuth kicks
things off with a possessed nurse massacring
a nursery full of shrieking newborns, and
it doesn't get much better from there.
The young age of the film's victims will
obviously be a major turn-off to some
viewers. But if you can get past the initial
shock of the back-to-back sadistic set pieces,
you'll be delighted to find a sharp-edged
supernatural procedural that pulls no
punches. Few films are this committed to
throwing the baby out with the bathwater.
The main character is Emmanuel Ritter,
a dedicated, gravel-voiced detective
with the physical presence of a bull and
the constitution to match. Still reeling
from the tragic death of his newborn son,
Detective Ritter finds himself embroiled in
an investigation into the Catholic conspiracy
responsible for the mass murder of countless
children. An ancient evil is dead-set
on clawing its way back into our world,
and the question of whether an emotionally shaken
detective and a would-be priest turned paranormal
investigator are the right men for the job
keeps the stakes high and palpable throughout.
If you've yet to come across Possum in your
moviegoing adventures, we're about to ruin your
day. There are a number of reasons why this film
will get under your skin: the oppressive mood,
the enigmatic storytelling, and the enormous,
human-faced, spider-legged puppet monster.
The plot follows Phillip, a disgraced
children's puppeteer who returns to his
hometown after losing his job for an
ominously unrevealed reason. While he
attempts to destroy his grotesque
marionette, he comes face to face
with his abusive uncle and the dark trauma
that has loomed over him his entire life.
Possum was written and directed by Matthew
Holness, whose short story of the same name was
originally published in the anthology collection
The New Uncanny: Tales of Unease. Horror writers
were prompted to use an essential human fear
and Sigmund Freud's essay on the uncanny as a
jumping off point. Holness ultimately drew
from not one but two phobias: puppets and
doubles. Considering that the Possum puppet also
boasts some freakishly horrible spider legs,
we'll go ahead and unofficially count that as
three phobias. The result of this gumbo of fear
is some truly adrenaline-pumping nightmare
fuel about a very sad man trying to destroy
something that's as much a representation of
his own trauma as a reflection of himself.
"The black, long-legged Possum-man.
Children, run! He'll eat and
smother, any child without a mother."
In the year 2000, the teenage Celeste is a victim
of a school shooting. Somehow, despite a serious
neck wound, she manages to survive, although the
same can't be said for all of her classmates.
In the wake of the tragedy, Celeste performs
at the memorial service an original song she
wrote while in the hospital, which then sets
her on the path to international pop stardom.
Vox Lux earns its place on this list thanks
to its alarming and emotionally devastating
depiction of a school shooting. Considering
the rage-inducing reality of how frequently
such tragedies occur in the United States,
the opening scene feels like a gut punch,
one where the effects linger
long after the credits roll.
That Celeste builds a career off of that
horrific act of violence never sits quite
right. And it isn't until the film's final
moments that the uneasy feeling comes into
clearer focus. Vox Lux is one of the few films
in recent memory to truly consider the lasting
psychological and cultural aftershocks
of school shootings, from the genuine,
lasting pain they inflict on survivors
to the commodification of that very pain.
Many films depict mental institutions as creepy
on the basis that older, better films told us
they were creepy. But 2018's Unsane proves that
there's still plenty of substance to be found by
shining a light on the institutional abuses
that continue to rage behind closed doors.
Shot entirely on an iPhone 7 Plus,
Unsane breaks from the shuffling
white-robed visual language of its modern
peers to underline the very real fears that
still plague the modern psychiatric
experience. The story follows Sawyer,
a woman who unknowingly commits herself
to a mental institution during a routine
visit to a therapist. Trapped in a situation
where she's treated as less than a person,
she's horrified to learn that her old stalker
works in the hospital as an orderly. But nobody
believes that she has an active restraining order
against this man. Either that, or nobody cares.
"I'm trying to tell you- you're not even
listening to me. I'm trying to tell you the man-"
"And I'm adding a course of
risperidone and lithium to your meds."
One of the more striking entries in
director Steven Soderbergh's ongoing
interest in recession-era anxiety, Unsane exposes
the greedy cost of the American healthcare system,
which is keen to harm healthy people if it means
a profit can be turned. Intentionally garish and
ugly to look at, this film is an
unnerving viewing experience made
all the creepier by its politically
charged approach to exploitation.
2019's Swallow follows Haley Bennett as
Hunter, a newlywed former saleswoman who
feels increasingly stifled by her extremely
comfortable and highly controlled domestic
life. You might look at Hunter's life
and think she has it all. The loving
husband. The lavish New York villa. A
baby on the way. So why is she so sad?
Under the increasingly crushing
pressure of her husband and in-laws,
Hunter's deep desire to be obedient and submissive
spills out in the form of a bizarre obsession:
a compulsive desire to swallow inedible objects.
It's the only thing that makes her feel in
control. But as Hunter's addiction with eating
hairpins, marbles, and tacks increasingly puts
her unborn child's viability at risk, her mental
health crisis reveals her husband's true colors.
Easily one of the most squirm-inducing
viewing experiences in recent memory,
Swallow is a haunting and isolating film about
the domestic imprisonment and abuse of power many
women are forced to endure. Much of the film's
disturbing power comes from its sound design,
which emphasizes the visceral quality of Hunter's
digestive rebellion. The sound of teeth scraping
across batteries is both unmistakable and
nauseating. There are plenty of movies that
are bloodier than Swallow, but not many
that are more difficult to sit through.